[Music]
when contemplating the meaning of life
it is easy to become confused and
disheartened as we find that there is no
conclusive overarching meaning that we
can hold on to when it comes to trying
to find some grand purpose that humanity
is serving to we can only really answer
questions with more questions and every
question we ask seems to only widen the
scope of our perspective of the universe
and consequently reduce the significance
of our existence for every step we take
away from ourself in order to get a
better view of what's around us we
become smaller and smaller so what can
we do how can we find meaning and
purpose in our life if we can't
understand or define our purpose outside
of it in the scope of the boundless and
perpetual universe our individual lives
are fundamentally meaningless but that
does not imply that they can't still be
filled with meaning as humans through
the power of imagination and higher
consciousness we have the incredible
ability to create meaning within the
meaningless we are creators able to
imagine meaning and attach it to the
things around us we can create and carry
out concepts like love morality and
success
we can create narratives out of our
lives and experience wonder and
inspiration
we are all like children playing games
of imagination with the world and it is
through this concept that we can uncover
life's meaning the meaning of human life
is simply to create to play and enjoy
the game of imagination as best we can
to accept that we do not understand our
overarching purpose and that we may not
even have one and instead work to
connect with and enjoy the life we can
create around us the relationships and
friendships that we form the passions
that we follow the values and outlooks
that we behold these types of things are
the true meaning of human life
we should appreciate our life not
because there is some grand purpose or
meaning behind it but because there is
endless meaning that we can create and
enjoy within it thank you for watching
if we found enjoyment and value in this
video please give it a thumbs up
share your thoughts in the comments
below and if you are not already be sure
to subscribe to our channel we are
constantly coming out with new videos to
help you experience life with clarity
and wonder